et notre émission n'est pas complètement
terminée voici un petit reportage était
me promener dans des studios qui ont
abrité bien des films depuis longtemps
déjà les studios de billancourt les
chairs studios de billancourt et là j'ai
trouvé sur un plateau dans un décor tout
à fait curieux qu'on va vous expliquer
dans un instant l'équipe de christian
gion au travail
alors
fête locale terry que soit la position
de l'appareil dont bernard et l'
excellence avec le huit manches
est-ce que vous prendrez votre leçon ok
des coups ça ici
comment s'appelle le flou pétrole
pétrole
vous avez peut-être déjà un petit peu
deviné c'est toute la saga pétrolières
si vous voulez les émirs et toutes les
choses qui tourne autour des émirs alors
moi ça m'a beaucoup amusé parce que on
en dit beaucoup de choses et pas
toujours exactes d'ailleurs et nous on a
monde on essaye de montrer comment les
choses se passent alors évidemment là
vous êtes dans un boeing spécialement
aménagé ces données puissent élire qui
est un petit peu imaginaire mais qu'on a
fait à partir des plans d'un boeing qui
n'a pas été construit mais vous tente on
avait étudié la construction dépasse pas
la ligne blanche de travers
m
chaussures se place à un petit peu oui
il faut il faut se ventiler comme on
peut avec les moyens du bord oui enfin
si on veut il ya cette anémie et comme
chacun sait les émirs ne sont pas tueur
mais ils sont plutôt ravise en bien et
pas du tout la même chose mais c'est une
main d'un traitement assez farce de 2
une aventure qu'ils ne le savons peu
existé et qui existe est en partie à la
fois donner du crédit au personnage du
relief comique on essaye oui le
personnage a du crédit
maintenant le relief comique ça on ne
sait jamais qu'au dernier moment
excellent j'ai mis au point d'abord tu
te dis ok merci le rideau on redescend
on y va on tourne
excellence j'ai mis au point une méthode
peu spéciale à votre honneur reprendre
rapidement et agréablement
nous allons commencer par le coup droit
la lumière
et
oui
mais mon panier loin devant
là
ambiance
oui
ah ah
à l'adjectif fin du mois
et